what yeah okay ha you can tell them I
sign when you hear the feedback welcome
to the 10th annual Christmas tree
lecture I just decided to start because
of 10 seconds had gone by nobody coming
through the door but now all those have
more people are coming to ignore well
that's okay I'll what I'll just talk
about about silly things at the
beginning this is the you know today we
have co-sponsors not only as computer
musings but it's also it's also
sponsored by Stanford computer forum
America's lecture series so we're
killing two birds with one stone
actually actually three or four birds
with one stone because I'm also
celebrating today the the 35th
anniversary of the art of computer
programming the which started to come
out in 1968 and and I'm the 30th the
30th anniversary of volume 3 which was
the last 1i got finished we should camp
out in 1973 so anyway so in the
Christmas spirit I decided to bring a
couple of spare copies of volumes 1 2 &
3 & duck and those will go to the people
who asked the best three questions so so
but it's not just random questions like
Mia but anyway I don't mind people
asking question this is a they said this
is an annual Christmas tree lecture it's
something we started a while ago and the
idea is that every year about this time
I i I've been talking about the most
cool thing I learned about trees during
the year and today I'm going to be
talking about something that that I
learned in July and played around with a
little bit the beginning august and it's
it goes back really two things that i
learned as undergraduate in my circuits
lab the the basic idea of spanning trees
and it in fact the first though on the
very first if not the first appearance
of trees in the mathematical literature
was the famous paper like
my care cough I think 1840s where he
were he based a lot of theory about
about circuits on the idea of spanning
food and people in electrical engineers
have had to learn / crafts love ever
since so I guess I start out by telling
you oh this is the first time those
since I have so many spiders first time
I've ever had a lecture with three
different posters announcing it so you
think so so anyway it got there be lots
of souvenirs at the Union okay um
spanning tree is it is this we start
with a graph and we and Anna graph I
think we have you have to know what a
graph is but it's a bunch of it's a
bunch of points called vertices and a
bunch of like connections between those
called edges or arcs and in the
announcement of today's lecture I have
this one example graph here with with
six vertices and the might as well make
those red huh since the actually it's or
engineers oh and and and I connected
them up very simply with making it into
triangles and then but now in order to
have a spanning tree you have to have a
subset of those edges have to have a
subset of the edges that connects up all
the points so if I got six points I'm
going to need to choose five edges in
order in order to connect them all up
and one way to do that of course is well
I got to connect this to one of the two
so I can go there well I could also
actually connect it to that one and then
from there I could connect say to their
and maybe over here and then I to get
this guy I can't come come either way so
let's say I went there so that's a
spanning tree and all the spanning trees
on a graph were important when kickoff
wanted to study electrical circuits that
were hooked together in this way
now on this poster that pronounced the
lecture it turns out that the that
you've seen many different spanning
trees of this of this same six-point
graph in fact well this one ought to
appear somewhere it sort of wraps around
there so where do I find that one hope
it's on here what we're here here it is
good okay we got it so there's it turns
out there's 54 spanning trees of this
graph and and that's not a triangular
number so i added a star at the top and
so we got but there but they all they
all appear here but there's more to it
than that because if you look there's a
little there's a little thread
connecting these guys going like this
and each one if you go from one spanning
tree to the next it it's as close as
possible to the previous one in the
sense that only one of the links has
changed so so in order to get from here
to here I deleted you know I i deleted
this guy and added the one at the bottom
to go from here to here i deleted one
more and add another one and so all you
know all 54 are connected by this by
this thread in his way so okay I i had
this on my computer a month ago and and
my wife walked in and said hey let's use
this on our Christmas card this year so
so there we are now I put on the web a
bunch of computer programs so that you
can play with the ideas that I'm going
to be discussing today so I'm going to
talk about a couple of algorithms that
will there are nice ways I think
beautiful ways to go through and find
all the spanning trees and it also in
this way that that they're just a small
change from one to the other because if
you ever have a problem where you want
to look at all spanning trees it usually
you can save time if you if you whatever
you're doing on the whole set of
spanning trees it probably doesn't have
to change much between one and the other
if only one
spanning trees it's changing at a time
so uh so I've got these right I've got
you see method I'm going to explain and
also the computer programs are on the
web if you just go to my homepage I'm
very lucky that they on most days this
year I have a 303 that our google you
just go to google and say do in and and
and you get my homepage so that's so i
don't have to tell me that so i don't
have to tell you but in my URL nuh and
and and then you and then you you click
under downloadable programs and you find
programs a lot spanning tree sessions
that i'm talking about and so if you
want to play with any of this stuff it's
it's not going to be easy to do and let
me show you first one of the programs ok
i put it here so what is called SP span
so if i type SB span then you get a
usage message says what you should do is
is uh oh oh i'm getting ahead of my
story you're close to give a formula and
then you have some other fighter craft
so let me talk let me talk about about
special kind of graphs for which the
algorithm is particularly pretty and
that is called the series parallel on
network fact uh I guess if black shows
up better all the way this green is a
good very Christmas color so series
parallel networks and naps with SP
stands for him and again is something I
had to learn when I was what pow when I
was a sophomore so the the idea of a
series-parallel network is very simple
we it's a way to connect a source to a
source to a terminal to a destination
terminal or just let's say two terminals
you and B and one of the simplest simple
serious peril network is just the one
that connects you to V it has only one
edge in it so that does a serious
problem
or if you have a several of series
parallel networks of say somehow between
u 1 and V 1 u 2 and V to use UK and VK
then you can you can connect them in
series and so that means that you that
you say v1 and you two are the same
vertex V 2 and u 3 and enjoying them up
like this look so the series connection
is you know u 1 V 1 let's all that safe
me to eat this is equals u 2 and V 2
equals u 3 and so on and finally we get
to the end at VK and here we had a UK
and EK minus 1 so now these these are
but between you and v1 it isn't just
have just an edge it's any serious
parallel network between you you want to
be one so it could it could be an edge
but it but it also could be a super edge
super edge being any anything I've
already defined as a serious trail
network and the other thing of course is
the parallel connection where where we
say that you want equal you to all the
use are equal and all of these are equal
and we just and we just you know hook
them all up like that so this this guy I
showed here is actually a special case
of a serious parallel network in second
in many ways but let's see if we can if
we can find at least one of them
these religious but disallow the episode
the empty set of edges is not a serious
parallel networking yumps sorry this is
this is it though that much much better
so you have a grammar that in fact you
can you can reduce it to the case where
you're combining only two things in
series or two things in parallel and and
we'll see a grammar for it but in a
minute but um so let's let's see if i
can get at least one triangle out of
this you see it to get a triangle that's
that's simply a serious this is a series
network here and then and here's another
one and so it pretty nose to in parallel
I get this triangle okay call this you
and this week and and since Vaughn asked
his question he's just trying to get one
of these books I know actually uh a
limit of five questions for first okay
okay all right but I'm so in fact let me
let me uh yeah sort of say that dash is
a serious peril let me give a grammar
for Syria spell networks because that's
what it was used as input to the SP span
program so a serious parallel network
which I might call n is it is eek eek is
he either e equal to a minus sign or a
or two ends followed by the letter S or
two ends followed by the letter P where
so otherwise i minus minus s represents
a network which means two guys in in
series minus minus P represents a
network which is two guys in parallel
and if I say minus minus s minus p that
would be this guy in parallel with one
more okay
and it or if I said minus minus minus SP
that would mean that that this that we
take this one and we hook and we hope it
we have another one in parallel on top
of it okay so you if I drew this one
upside down i would call it- mess anyway
that's a formula for the triangle and
now if i want to add another triangle to
that that's easy as just another another
thing in series so i have minus minus
minus well minus minus s minus p for
example and then minus minus s minus p
for this triangle and then hook them in
series so that means putting this after
that and then okay but now i want that
to be let's call this u and v now and
then i want you know to put in parallel
another guy here so let's let's go to
minus minus s minus p and another p and
that and that would hook them together
so so anyway there's a lot of networks
can be can be regarded as as serious
peril network and enough of them to to
be interesting and so so i got this
program SP span where I give a formula
and the formula that another formula for
the same tree the one I actually used is
it here and the computer was uh was this
but three minus is sp3 MSSP amount of
SPN another SP to hook everything
together now and so what my computer
replied was it said it it said there
were 54 spanning trees and it also told
how long it took to do the calculation
now a lot of times when I'm
instrumenting my programs now to find
out how good the algorithm is I can't
memory references because of the way
computers are going the memory
references are the things that are more
much more important than anything else
and and if I just count microseconds it
means nothing next year so but mens are
something that are going to stay the
same well like continue writing my book
so the experiments that I make now I you
know so i got algorithms i rate them by
my memory references and and this
particular one took 117 mems to get get
you known to get going and then 830 9
more and it found 54 spanning trees good
that's that's the right number okay now
if i add another another thing to my
command line so i said verbose then it
it tells me you know what the what the
trees are the first bank tree is a CFG I
where you have to know what that what a
CFG I means and the convention is that
sp- SP honest minus minus sbsb the
convention is that the letters ABCD are
in order are used to denote the the
edges that we're starting with I mean
the basic edges and then so actually you
know this note this notation allows us
to build a tree get that trees where we
have a and B and C and and this s joins
B and C and and then actually I call
that capital a the first I'll leave all
the SNP's are going to are going to be
given capital letter and then in
parallel we reconnect these so let's be
and then I formed d e f the same way so
that will be C and D coming here and GHI
the same way not e f and then connect in
series of the first to know the last two
so this is G and then family page so so
this is a you know that this big tree
represents a series-parallel breath a
series-parallel network there's plenty
of good seats on the on the edges and in
the front guys so and so AC AC fgi it
turns out his comp is going to be one of
these you know the first one at the top
at the top of my page there and then and
then it tells me oh that then my
computer output tells me then to get the
next one you you add H and delete I and
then you need to take away G and put I
back in and and so on a flea keep
flashing back and forth and so so so
these instructions rather what what I
used to generate the the pictures that
were on the announcement of the page by
the way Julian from the computer forum
made me this is great put this great
poster so that you can see them all in
large sizes and so so here they are okay
so in the and in fact what is the what
is the code the code is a b c d the way
i actually did it was d e f this way and
then GHI like that you can't see ya oh
ok so this is the this is the way that
this is the correlation between you know
between the trees that you see and the
and the computer output that i had to
help telling about the trees turn out
yeah question
guaranteed request for the graduate
visitation always one to one there's
there is some ambiguity if I have like
minus minus minus SS because the because
two things in series the S operator is
is associative and and so you could
write you know you could have grouped it
in different ways minus minus s minus s
is the same as minus minus minus but in
this particular case and since always
have series alternating with parallel I
believe dis write it this is a parallel
no wait a minute I'm sorry this this was
a series that this was a pair Deaver
series these are all parallel and so
this was serious but this was parallel
so the H&B I should have really put
together and I should have made that one
glorious one glorious node here on top
my me I actually i would i would
combined it into a three all right wait
HS now this is us this is a series node
this is a parallel so I of getting
pretty messy if this guy this guy and
that guy are all are all really let's
call it I don't know be so redraw it i
have i have three guys in parallel at
the top and and then you know and then i
have b and c here and then I've got
under this one I have under here
okay so d e f g h i and then now i think
my program actually signs the capital
letters from the top probably instead of
from the bottom but the main thing is
you can get a tree and in this forum if
i if i allow myself to have three way
branching four-way branching the
representation is unique but I insist
now that that I alternate like if I have
a parallel at the topped and everything
on the second level is serious and
everything on the third level is
parallel again and it's strictly
alternating and that turns out to be
helpful for the speed of the algorithm
the algorithm would work if I kept
binary structure and didn't didn't suck
these two parallels together but it's
actually much faster or two to realize
this this way this branching structure
Tom to be the so remember we're trying
to find all spanning trees and so what
is a spanning tree looked like on a on a
serious parallel graph well it's pretty
easy to see what a spanning tree is on
the simplest series-parallel graph right
it's got one edge that's the spanning
tree you had a hook close together but
now what if we have several things in
series you know so we call it we got
these super edges um between certain
vertices and and there and they're
connected in series what are the
spanning tree looked like in this way
well I think it's obvious that the only
way we're going to get a spanning tree
on this is to have a spanning tree in
each putt in each of the parts that we
hooked in series because we have to be
able to connect everything everything
together so that's the way so so
recursively if you know how to find us
you know spanning tree for any serious
trail network or if you find know how to
find all spanning trees of the series
girl network then things are hooked in
in series all you have to do is find all
spanning trees of each of the guys in
series
no brainer now how about if we if we
hook them in parallel this gets a little
more interesting what are they what are
the Spanky looked like by the way your
question comes pretty good so come see
me after so so now what are the spanning
trees look like in this case I I'm going
to have to have a connection from one to
the other yeah you've got a good one of
the spanning tree yes so I have to
choose one of these four guys and put a
spanning tree on it but on the other
ones I've got it I have to have
something that's a little different and
i'm going to call it a near spanning
tree near spanning tree is something
that's that instead of having instead of
connecting everything together it almost
connects everything together in a sense
that if i added one more edge between it
puts everything together everything the
two into two parts but not three so if
you have n n vertices you need n minus 2
edges and those cycles to make a near
spanning tree so so but I do need a new
spanning tree on all the other so so to
get a new spanning tree then ok so to
get all the spanning trees of this
network what I have to do is run it is
is run through first of all four
possibilities choosing the guy who's
going to have the spanning tree and then
once I've made that choice then I find
all near spanning trees on the others
and all spanning trees on the one that
I've chosen ok but now that's a new prop
that's a new problem I got to figure out
how to find new spanning trees of of all
these guys ok a new spanning tree of the
simplest case is easy no edge a nearest
bank tree of a series is what
one you pick one guy and find all near
spanning trees of that one and all
spanning trees or the other it's very it
you know so serious is it dual two
parallel all the things that you say
about series and parallel you just turn
them upside down you change near
spanning two spanning and and and you
got it so because for parallel what are
the nearest banning ones look like
they're near spanning on all four so to
run through all the sneers banning of a
parallel connection you want to run
through all newest banks of the of the
two things so once i got this of this
tree structure like this i can actually
you know sort of say what all the
Spanky's are going to look like and and
here's what here's what it is i I let
let me remind you this is a parallel
note at the top level here and a serious
level and then parallel and series
alternating and then let's suppose I
want to get put a one up here which
means I want a spanning tree and then I
then a zero will mean that i want a near
spanning tree now i'm going to designate
of 11 child of each node in the tree so
so let me let me let me for example
designate the leftmost child that's the
way i get started in this process and
and the idea is that the designated
child always gets the same value as as
the as the parent so is it gets a value
of one and now the other children always
get the type of the parent the type of p
is 0 and the type of s is one so
oh so I so the other children are going
to be zero that's that's my rule for
propagating values down from the top of
the tree so Norton what I get it I have
this tree and I at every bed every node
I designate one of the children and and
for example I've designate all the left
children and now my rule is of copy the
value to your designated child and then
copy your type to your to your
undesignated children so p is of type 0
as is of type 1 so so the 0 is going to
go to designated child here but the type
it's one is is see the 0 is going to
because it's going to go down here to
the 0 at this node and the type is going
to go here one now these are parallel
notes so so 0 is going to pass to the d
but the type is going to stay here and
then this cereal is going to going to be
like this if i did it right the one is a
parallel node so it but the g is one but
the ages of 0 I mean this notice 0 and
then H gets a zero and the I gets the
type of S is a 1 so now now the values
that the leaves here are whether or not
we include the thing in the spanning
tree or not so it's according to this if
I did it right a SI f GI is supposed to
be a spanning tree and in fact it's
supposed to be the one that aha look at
that a CFG I makes me feel good ok so so
now this is the the basic idea of the
zero always means of make an on-ear
spanning tree one always means make us
pantry and you can see from the rules
that would that we gave that this is
actually faithful wait now in order to
get all the spanning trees then what we
have to do is just play this game with
all the different designations of the
children with one exception if a guy if
a parallel node has a zero on it or or
if a serial node has a one on it
it doesn't matter what the designated
child is because a parallel no with a
zero on it of all those children are
zero and a serial mode with a one on it
all his children are our one so in that
case it doesn't make you know so so what
we really want to do is if the I call it
an easy and an easy node in the tree
it's an easy node if the value equals
the type of the node a parallel note is
zero or the serial note is one that's an
easy note that means that the whichever
child is designated now is irrelevant
you don't have to vary the the thing so
the recursive rule for getting all the
spanning trees is go to you know if
you're an easy node just take all of
this all of the you know sort of bump
all your all your children to go through
all of their configurations but if
you're not an easy node then for each
each of your children in turn make those
the designated child and and and do
everything and then go to the next child
and go to the next job and all right now
I don't have time to go into into
further details because I would love
other stuff I want to talk about but but
it's but there's no there there are nice
methods then once we've got this this
beautiful recursive pattern to to to
have all the kids doing their thing one
at a time for example if you want to get
the Cartesian product of three of you if
you want to get if you have two children
in each one knows how to generate all of
its spanning trees then you can ask the
sks say the first child to to go through
and and and do all of it and then you
make one change in the leg you know and
then it finishes and then you make one
change to the next child and then say
the first child go through again and
continue on until until both it you know
but the first what you it's crazy to see
how you can make it so that only one
check one change is made at a time
provided I tell you one more
a thing and that is if I chick once like
once I move my designated child from one
place to the other I'm only changing one
I'm only changing one value and the
reason is so i will rotate my body yeah
very good so what I'm saying is that
when you when i switch mutton suppose I
had had decided instead of designated
this guy to designate this guy well what
actually happens is that only two are
going to have to change because there's
a path through designated children all
the way down to a leaf which has which
has the same value as you and there's a
path from the from the newly from a new
guy all the way down through his
designated kids down to that leaf and so
it's so there's going to be always at
the bottom when I'm changing from if I
if I move this player from from this
branch to this branch it's always going
to mean that some below apparel it's
always going to mean that that the one
that used to be designated is going to
go from one to zero of Ghana the leaf
and the other one goes from 0 to 1 and
those changes are only affect to two
things so all the operations that we're
doing are simple changes to the final to
the final tree any questions on it yep
the notes that you start from them you
know that's pretty arbitrary that's true
you know they can have a graph with one
choice it doesn't have a series and
parallel but if you change the potential
that's a good point that sometimes the
vertices that you designate no.8 that it
actually is not true though and I'll
explain why in a big path before we go
but but the but the actual designation
that you do will happen well I might as
well give you the answer right now we
get off the stack so suppose you have a
graph that has that's a series-parallel
graph then there has to be some
of you know it could be the base craft
but it but it's not the base craft then
there has to be something that was
combined at the last step like us like
it was two things put together in series
so that means there's a vertex of degree
to a vertex that has exactly two of two
neighbors because that was the last you
know egg some some serious connection at
the bottom means that there's a vertex
of degree 2 so every time you have a
vertex of degree 2 you just replace it
you delete that vertex and replace that
by one edge yep okay and you keep doing
that until there are no vertices of
degree 2 now you look for two vertices
that have multiple edges between them
that would be a parallel connection and
every time you have a multiple of you
you you change that to a single
connection because you say that was that
was done by a parallel step and and and
so then you've got a graph you know and
then maybe now you've got a vertex of
degree 2 and so you keep on doing this
until there are no multiple edges no
vertices of degree 2 so you're left with
a graph has only one edge between atmos
between any two vertices and every
vertex of degree 3 or more and no matter
what you know soaks so if you had set up
with a serious parallel network you
would reduced it just to a single point
but otherwise you haven't so it doesn't
so it's you know from this point of view
it's a mistake to try to to tell what
the U and V are I guess you're right
that Sutton you certain you and v's
you're never going to you're never going
to do but I guess you oh yeah yeah you
could do you could choose u and V stupid
me that's true you could like like to
two things that are hooked in series and
then yeah like you said a diamond then
you could say all I wanted to get from
there to there and I can make it yeah
but not in general though I'm not really
although you know people who actually do
try to communicate with the circuits do
care what u and v are
for spanning trees it doesn't matter so
so it's a mistake to insist on your U
and V but but I like to think of of the
U and V just because each each basic
unit is it is actually this super edge
idea instead of that the basic recursive
structure is much nicer to think of it
that is if the way I presented yeah one
more question then I want to move on it
seems to be the vector using U and V and
the hull development with standing fees
and near spanning trees because you
always want your Spanish is the separate
UV that's exactly right yeah it may be
not only not any old old old near
spanning tree it has to be a new
spanning tree that breaks the connection
that U and V are that the connection
Mewtwo v is the connect yeah okay yeah
come up well you're going to have to
have a tiebreaker maybe at the end Tom
now okay but anyway you can play with
this program and also this the
specification here gory detail you if
you think it could give the you know if
you give another thing on the command
line say extremely verbose then you you
know that then you then it tells you
what's in the data structures and and
and it tells you what the you know what
what the leaves are are doing what is
swapping all this stuff up and these the
program if you download is well I did it
with really large fonts here so that you
could you can read it today but i
usually don't get it in this indices and
and it actually the program is quite
sure at the actual album that generates
all the all the spanning trees fits on a
page rather nicely but here's here's an
example that I that I work through in
the notes of the program themselves you
see here's the
the syntax that I gave which is actually
and and if you read through here you see
the you know the way the program runs
and that all the different error
messages that you can get if you know if
you could break out and there's a you
know the theory is described in there as
well so it so anything that you that I
said today it got them understand you
can find it you can find a theory given
here next of course there's lots of
graphs in the world it that aren't
serious peril in fact if all graphs were
serious peril we would that you can't we
be able to solve the Traveling Salesman
problems and many other problems because
series paragraphs are known to be the
graphs whose tree width is two and and a
lot of people have studied algorithms
that work on graph on graphs that have
bounded tree width and if the tree with
this three is much better
computationally than if it's four and so
on but series Cara the simplest case
where the tree width is only two but so
let's take now the thing that started me
honest this whole thing it was the idea
that I learned from the summer and a
thesis master's thesis actually that
came out of 1997 i believe by malcolm
smith at the university of victoria or
we end and he had a really nice way to
solve the pantry problem for an
arbitrary graph and so that's his this
program which is empty funny and his
method is illustrated by another program
that you can download called grace pan
so yeah Malcolm Smith 1997 University
and I and so I'm you know again Oh Bob
instrumented the program so if you look
at the at the code and Counting memory
references if you look at a typical
place in the program here I put in front
of every statement you know double o
kaanha that just means I made to Rick
memory references in this line and you
know I actually do this all by hand
because I consider some things are known
to be in registers and not not really
references to memory I'm not going to
trust a compiler to optimize things the
right way in all cases so I so I
instrument it myself by hand it doesn't
take long and his idea is again if it is
this you have a graph and and you say
find all the precursor problem that
you're doing is buying all spanning
trees where the first one of the first
starts with a given near spanning tree
okay like new spanning tree so again I
choose n minus 2 edges that that are
enough to hook the thing into two
different convos so the first bank and I
can and so it's one of the things given
to me is is that I want whatever my
first bank tree is it should it I know n
minus 2 of the edges in it only one more
to find and here's the idea you see if
you have a graph
and then there's a there's an edge in it
somehow some somewhere hearsay from you
to be and then there's also lots of
other stuff in the graph call this edge
e then there are two kinds of spanning
trees the ones that use e and the ones
that don't use e so now let's take a
look at those two cases what are this
what are the spanning trees look like
that that that use edge E and it turns
out that what we do is we've conform to
grab G dot e which means contract this
edge into a single into a single vertex
social shrink to you know imagine that
you and we are the same and get rid of
edgy and now we got a graph with with
one less vertex and one less edge and
and we find all of its spanning trees
and then we and then we add to those and
those are spanning trees of the whole so
so all spanning trees of also spanning
trees of G equal spanning trees of G
attractive with e Union the ones that
don't use e and these are the spanning
trees of G minus e which was so this was
one notation used for g minus Z so this
is a recursive structure saying you know
if we if we note that each of these are
smaller graphs so so we can so so so we
do it but we also said that the the
solace banging trees we were going to be
given a certain and a certain near tree
where we started so what happens is that
at the end after week so we start out
and we generate all spanning we're given
a near tree and
so the near tree is say e 1 e 2 edges n
minus 2 so I contract e 1 and now I find
all spanning trees of on G contracted
with e 1 and and then I a d1 to those so
the first one that I actually get it's
going to turn out recursively the e 2
will be included and I mean you see a
near spanning tree on the reduced graph
will be will use edges et tu through a
TN minus two so i'll find some spanning
tree ke n minus 2 and en again the
government will find some some some ian
minus 1 that that does it and then it
will go through and do its phases and
it'll end up with some random thing to
f2 FN minus 1 some other Spanky when
it's all done so whatever if whatever it
finishes with is the nearest is the near
spanning tree of the whole graph and so
sort so at this point I delete that and
I ask for all spanning trees of G minus
e1 that that include that which the
first one includes f2 through FN minus 1
so the next thing the algorithm is going
to do is then figure out some new f1 and
it will run through all of those that's
the idea of the recursion and there's a
really cute way to dispatch to put these
all all in memory so that you can
instead of using a stack for the
recursion you actually have a linear
list where all the things you're
supposed to use our are sitting there on
the list with a little hole looked a
little hole in the middle of it and I
don't have time to go through the
details but I can show you how to how
the program works when you play with it
Tom so it's it runs exactly the same as
as a great portal oh yeah I got another
program to play that's called SP graph
and what you do so if i run kept
forgetting how to use it so i run SP
graph program and i give a formula if i
happen to have a simple graph which is a
series paragraph i can give the formula
and and it will create a file that
represents that graph in the in the
format used by Stanford Stanford graph
basely a whole bunch of programs that i
have for dealing with with graphs and
and other come to our logarithms and and
so it makes the graph base graph demo gb
and and then I then I run my program
grace pan on on demo gb and says oh okay
I found 54 spanning trees 6,000 and some
MEMS Oh as you would expect since this
grace band program is more general it's
it if not going to work as efficiently
on expanding on a serious paragraph the
series calligraphic it only took a less
than a thousand altogether but so it
took about six times as long but it's a
much more general program and did find a
54 spanning trees and again we can ask
for distance doesn't matter what what
what you put on the command line as long
as you have another another argument on
the command line like I put a plus sign
here that just that gives you the you're
both information and told how long it
took to you know to get going and then
and it also tells you it not the numbers
that has assigned to all the all the
edges of the graph and so is your first
spurt first bank between the second one
and again if you ask for after the 54
then if you ask for extra verbose then
you get a lot of gory details about
exactly exactly how it goes about and
the program is is actually much shorter
than the program for the series
paragraph case this this program
you has to prepare the graph in and it
has a fairly simple but has had lots
lots of printouts up just to do this
verbose printing so describe the method
here that I just described to you and
and when they actually get to the code
it's it's it's quite it's quite simple
and and that the only complication is
that we're shrinking the graph and then
we have to backtrack and unshrink it
again oh I left that one little
complication we don't want to look at if
G might if G if taking out eone
disconnects the graph then I don't want
to do that step because it's called a
bridge I have to have a connected graph
so so I have to make a test that after i
finished after i finished looking at
this one I have to test whether it is
well whether i'm done at all because I
so so so I make it but you know so i
deleted this edge and then and i make
sure there's still way to get from u to
V if not then I just don't then I dip
then I'll have to worry about this guy
at all it's not connected ok so I have
to do that but I so that's the point
here it says you know so I shrink it but
then i have to unshrink and if it's not
a bridge deleted and remember the edge
that you've changed and and I would go
to statements in this program don't be
shot and the beauty is actually that the
unshrinking method we keep the keep the
representation of the graph as a doubly
linked list and this means that undoing
is extremely simple a couple years ago I
gave a lecture one of my lectures was
about what I called dancing links which
is which is a technique for undoing that
requires only very small changes to a
data structure so we can shrink the
graph by removing edges and
and changing couple links so we can
unshrink the graph with without much
much extra work and then with a much
better way to do a lots of common 12
programs that it that require require we
require backtracking on doing so the
dancing Winx method which I presented in
connection with a completely different
problem turns out works on many many
different process many different methods
and then British detection is just a bar
we're just doing a breadth-first search
so the whole of the the whole code turns
out to be to be quite short as it when I
want to put it into our computer
programming it's going to it's going to
be an algorithm only about nine or ten
steps lon so that's the experience that
you have with that and up I can show you
one other program that I have oh gosh
there's lots nuts output though it does
all this work no wonder it took six
thousand men okay drawing done but it
has to do everything you do you have to
be able to undo and you have to check
for bridges host okay so but this was
the extra verbose output telling a very
handy when I was debugging and what the
program was so simple it really didn't
take much time to debug since there was
almost nothing get wrong however then I
wrote a program called gray SP span and
this is the one that is guaranteed to be
efficient and here's the idea of look at
the program gray SP span which bacteria
to this program combines the idea of a
gray span and SP span resulting in a
glorious routine that generates all
spanning trees changing only 100 time
with guaranteed efficiency in a sense
that the total running time it is a
constant times M plus n plus T if there
are M edges and vertices and T spanning
trees that's as good as you could expect
to have it if you're going to generate
all the spanning tree
you can count all the spanning trees by
evaluating determinants but just saying
we want to generate them and so now this
program again has the same conventions
as the other programs but it uses the
idea i mentioned a while ago that first
it if you've got a graph in and has it
it has several edges between the same
two vertices these are called parallel
edges so we say ok let's combine those
two into one and and if we if we have a
vertex set that has degree 2 1 vertex
only has two neighbors we can eliminate
that vertex and and consider the two
edges that we used to join that vertex
to be a super edge between them again in
fact the word super edge turned out to
be to be fairly long so I decided
instead to to call it a bond and that
turned out to be a nice nice four letter
word at work now so so let's say that a
bond is a it is that you know something
that happens in this recursive process
and I start out with the graph and I and
I consider that its edges are bonds and
then it but then if I have two parallel
bonsai combine them into one bond if I
have if I have two bonds in series they
combine them into one bond until finally
i have a graph left where where it's
either a trivial graph only one point or
it's got its got at least three bonds
coming into every every vertex um ok and
now the in this in this graph I can use
Smith's algorithm the the idea is that I
suppose I run through and find all
spanning trees of the graph with the
bond with me so I have a grant let's
suppose that I suppose for example that
my graphs has reduced to the smallest
the smallest non-trivial graph that
thought that doesn't has four vertices
and every and they're all connected to
each other so yeah so this just a
complete graph on four things is the
simplest way to have it every vertex of
degree 3 or more and and and and so
suppose that my graph Bob but but each
of these are not really edges but
they're their bonds that means that they
could be any serious peril network
between between the two edges okay now
suppose then that I find one spanning
tree of this guy maybe maybe this one
then then what that really means is I
want to find all I I want to find all
spanning trees of these of these series
parallel networks and all near spanning
trees of the of the ones that I haven't
used so so in other words i plied
Malcolm Smith's algorithm to this big
guy and and for every spanning tree it
outputs I run through all the spanning
trees of the bonds and all that are
included in all this island near
spanning trees of all the ones that
aren't included and I can do that just
changing one one branch at a time not
only that but as you look at Smith's
algorithm you know you delete a bond and
then all of a sudden you've got a you've
got vertices of degree 2 and the graph
contracts again so all the time you're
replying this idea you're you're you're
when you reduce the graph bike by
shrinking together of by shrinking one
of the edges it out and bring the points
together or by deleting one of the edges
again you have a chance to build further
bonds this leads to a really interesting
data structure and I'm doing an undoing
situation where the this serious
parallel graphs that that are coming
keep changing all the time and it turned
out to be one of the most interesting
programs i ever you know certainly the
most interesting when i did this summer
and it and here it's a fairly chunky
piece of code i mean enough well 5050
parts to the to the to the program each
each part is well in fact talk a little
bit about debugging it because i have
here's the here's the data structure
where's the data structures for the bond
okay here's the data structure so so a
bond you have a type and a value that we
that we had in our in our series
parallel algorithm we had a left child a
left sibling of in family right sibling
the designated child the final dedicated
chalice are going around the circle we
have then I up things I needed for to
control my my algorithm that goes
through in gray code order and I have
left and right in a list of that's also
implementing the gray court order up and
down and then I have in order to undo
there wasn't enough enough information
to data structure unless I introduce two
more fields and I took two additional
history values so it's a huge they've
tortured with a lot of redundancy so
when I have to debug it when I have to
debug it I find it very important to
have savvy check routines so the sanity
check and then I can then I put flags in
there to say what kind of sanity I want
to check at a particular time has I'm
debug I got to find because I the other
was going to run in a long time and it's
going to end
really if if a program runs for 10
minutes and then all of a sudden it
hangs you want to know when the data
structure first got got out of order
instead of instead of a few minutes
after the actor after you had a missing
link in it and started to screw up so
you know so then I have all these checks
on the redundancy go again that's best
makes the program longer for sure when
you look at the attack what happens to
do when you're when you're shrinking
nose and let's see where are we here
make Spears make them there's lots and
lots of of data structure manipulations
doing undoing deleting unbelieving and
so what happened was I I tried this
algorithm out on the complete graph
first with you know with four nose is
this the simple case where there's four
vertices and everything check up and to
make sure first that would work and then
I tried it on a complete graph of five
notes now while you're working on a
complete graph of five nodes it it
deletes edges and so you get every other
graph somehow in the process and and so
uh any bugs you know I I just I was just
testing it on complete graph instead of
on on other graphs because it because uh
as as you start with a complete gravity
delete edges you run into lots lots of
other graphs anyway and so it worked on
it you're after did another five bugs
and I and it worked on the complete
graph of of six vertices and then I
tried it on the complete graph of seven
vertices the number of spanning trees is
going in fact going up and up and up
it's the end of the n minus 2 but still
not too bad and so sure enough a few
more bugs showed up in San vertices but
then I did eight worked fine and I did
nine I worked fine and I did ten gain it
crashed and I and I found for more bugs
okay it's a and but now I'm sure it's
correct although I haven't really gone
and incidentally the running time for
generating all in the complete graph of
10 things that the number of mems was
was three point that was one point nine
billion only so it wouldn't have been
bad to go are you know to go up to the
to the to the next que sólo that's it's
going from 10 to the eighth spanning
trees to 11 to the ninth but it's still
I could you know I could go up a little
little further but I'm convinced that
it's working now but you might find it
not if you if you download it from the
web and try it but these these sanity
check routines were extremely important
because I could have every time I did
anything to the graph I would then do a
sanity check and I would find out oh
yeah that's where the bug is because
there's so many cases that arising in
these changes to a data structure it has
lots of identity and I believe that
whenever you're running a program that
has such data structures that that's a
very valuable debugging aid and so I
didn't we didn't take really too long
all I said here program tester was t as
an Arab morning um ok so there's
comments as well now the other thing I
wanted to tell you is why I can guess
why this I can guarantee that this
program is efficient and the the because
if you look at at the recursive method
you see that the ugh you know I really
in order to change with them going to
need to change to get from one thing to
another I'm not allowed to do much
calculation if I'm only allowed a
constant amount of operation / / output
amortized over the whole thing and the
reason is that um that I that I was able
to prove that there are lots and lots of
spanning trees if the graph is reduced
and so here's a here the result that
that I want to but I want to explain to
the next few minutes it's a theorem that
that I asked to the people who ought to
know if it had been proved before and it
seems to be new as if vewy is any
connective multigraph without loops you
know you have to have all these
hypotheses so connected means that you
have a least one spanning tree
multigraph means that it that you're
allowed to have Carol edges between two
vertices but loops means you can't have
any edges from a vertex to itself that
then it has total number spanning trees
is traditionally called kappa of g the
number of spanning trees so the number
of spanky that has is greater than the
product d 1 minus 1 d 2 minus 1 to the N
minus 1 spanning trees where DJ is the
valence or the degree of vertex chain so
the number of neighbors of the vertex
including multiple neighbors if there's
a most rare so so this is the theorem
all in particular if you have a graph
that doesn't reduce anymore all these
these are at least three there's no
vertex of degree to the pub degree two
or one okay a vertex of degree one is an
end point that you know really so so
that means then that I have at least 2
to the N you know the square root of two
to the end of spanning trees this is
this grows exponentially within
gives me plenty of time to to do the
other calculations that I need to to
figure 22 now to figure out the series
parallel working on the bonds and and
that's the that's the reason so it's
because of this theorem that I can
guarantee the efficiency of the that oh
that's super method you you can you can
show that without the without the super
method it's it's kind of embarrassing is
that with a cycle and you try to find
all the spanning trees of a cycle and
there's only n of them but it takes you
n squared time to read it so so you need
a theorem like this in order to do it
okay now the proof is if I'll just
sketch it for you and I suppose you
could reduce this proof to to approve
using determinants of if you were really
good at matrix theory and so those of
you want to check it you could but
anyway the case one is that G is
connected it is on sorry I ok let's say
let's uh let's suppose U and V our
vertices that are connected by K edges
to each other and then there's other
vertices are other edges make up going
out to other place to other to the rest
of the graph let's say a on this side
and be on this side and and I take g of
is my original graph and g2g one is is g
with u and v i identified and i was
collapsed all these shrink all k these
edges together into a point and g2 is g
with those K edges are removed so then
then the number of spanning trees of g
is equal to k times a number of spanning
trees of g 1 plus the number of entries
of g2 that's easy to see have to choose
one of these edges
and do it on the others or you can do
this way ok so now I use induction and I
want to prove it so so so these are
smaller graphs and there and so a case
one is that g2 is connected then I can
if g2 isn't connected then I couldn't
use the induction hypothesis because I
need to be connected multi-grade so in
that case then what am I saying what
cave cap of g 1 is is greater than or
equal square root of a plus B minus 1
times alpha and cap of g 2 is greater
than or equal to a minus 1 v minus 1
alpha where alpha represents product of
the degrees of all the other vertices
besides you and v well you see what's
happening is g1 I've combined these
these vertices together so the new vert
the new the new thing has has a plus B
neighbors and that ends so the degree
minus 1 and my formula is a plus B minus
1 alpha represents the product over all
the other vertices well in g2 I've
deleted these two guys and so now I have
ate it so now you have has degree A&V
has degree be in soap and so I have this
one so all I have to show is is the
humps so I just have to prove then that
K times square root of a plus B plus 1
plus the square root of a minus 1 B
minus 1 is greater than a plus B greater
or equal to a plus B minus 1 times
a pay plus k minus 1 and v plus k minus
1 yeah i just have to prove this what if
a if a B is greater than zero so if a
and B are both greater or equal one then
then you just have to prove this in a
simple calculus to do it so that's
second case is there are no such u and v
U and V where with with g2 connected in
other words it's always a bridge
whenever you have whenever other
parallel edges have our bridges here
okay so every multiple edge of G is a
bridge and that means it's a tree of
retreat except for parallel edges and so
if there's a vertex of degree 1 the the
result is obvious because if any of the
degrees is one you get zero here and and
the statement is obvious and if you
don't have a vertex of degree 1 then
you've got some end point though be in
every tree so there's an end point where
where it's not going to anything except
except V and there's k vertices here ok
and so so the degree of view is K the
degree of V is k plus 1 plus X because
it's obviously if there's no there is
pizza there's some other guys here and
ok so they're not it there's a simple
case analysis of talk and depending on
depending on what X is if X is is
positive it's it's easy if x is 0 it's
easy and
and so that you know the proof I'm near
the end of time so so again we just have
to verify a few like in the case where
I'm sorry if u and V were here my
theorem would be that k is greater than
the square root of K minus 1 K minus 1
which happens to be a tight inequality
so you know if there weren't anything if
there weren't anything on the other side
of being what what if there wasn't
anything on the side of my theme was
certainly true so so uh god so i put
here and you know so i have to have to
consider this case but it does work out
very nicely and so that's that that's a
theorem says that that there's lots and
lots of spanning trees if you don't if
you don't have the collapsing that other
and that's up that's the best friends so
then then it's easy to make a proof that
the total total running time is linear
though we said well so does it really
save a lot of time compared to the
simple algorithm that has a bad that you
know that doesn't do too well on cycles
and the answer was on the complete graph
it the simple algorithm took 3.8 billion
mems and and the complicated algorithm
took 1.9 billion so i factor 24 all my
programming but I learned a lot well as
programming and it's always nice to have
a theoretical guarantee makes it looks
like you you know like you know like
you've done your homework more questions
any find out bound on starting the upper
bound yeah there's there are some up
about what's this is actually there's
their upper bounds but they're like we
take off the square root here I mean I
can't remember what it is I often it'll
have it in my book but but there is a
upper bound based on degrees but
certainly fruits for example the the
product of the degrees is an upper bound
but that's maybe to cure
yeah but I don't remember that yeah not
a bad question though yeah pretty hard
for me to keep for our no best questions
in is yuck so g1 g2 cars but at the
units of your two operations but this
one is the unit of this the P little
graph is the unit identified you've got
the never met by your definition draft
and the single point as a empty
disconnected is another one where they
did the respective units to this are you
say in a special case of trees with
multiple edges yeah then then yeah and
this this this bound is seems to be
tight really tight only in the case of a
path that has that that has met like
like it seems to it seems to be where
you have a we have something like this
lots and lots of edges and then one and
then last night's edges and then one
last month Utley and you let these these
numbers go to infinity then then it
shows that that my theorem is the best
possible in the sense that you can't I
can't put a 1 plus epsilon here for any
positive photographer is just another
but a bullet edges up it has two nodes
that are disconnected the if I multiply
by all the case then some of the DVR
that's a night thats it thats a good
idea to think about that later leave out
the word multigraph the reason i wanted
it to be multigraph though is because of
the induction you see because as soon as
you as soon as you collapse these two
together all of a sudden you're getting
parallel edges because some of these
some of these things you is connected to
us already and he was already connected
to them too
so those to compare alleges and you
can't use the induction easily yes can
regenerate spanning trees using both
deletion rather than expedition thank
you is using what modulation vertex
deletions follow vertex galicia spanning
tree is really an edge property and it
seems find all the spanning trees and
that's what that's a delete one note and
everything and touching it and then yeah
okay well that's a good research problem
maybe we'll come up with a faster
algorithm yeah but at the moment this is
what this is what I know did it take you
to write the column well let me take
actually what I spent I spent four days
trying to to do the following which is
totally academic the spanning the SP
span program their series parallel it
since it had this beautiful algebra and
all this duality and things going in
here I said okay now I'm going to go
further and I'm not am I I'm going to
write a loop LaSalle driven a lupus
algorithm means that that not only is
the total running time linear in the
amount of output but but I don't allow
myself to to to ever do unbounded amount
of computation you know yeah the the
running time of this program is the
total running time is proportional to
the number of spanning trees but between
the tenth and eleventh spanning tree it
might take a while and then then it will
start generating lots not the spanning
trees against fast so the old amortized
running time is linear in anything but
but what if you say that no you're not
you put an absolute bound on the amount
of time between spanning trees and trees
have to come out at a constant pulse
rate and I was I was almost there to
having a lupus algorithm for the series
parallel spanning trees and then and
then it would it would break down and so
then I had been done another two hours
would go by I thought of another way and
then I would then that would fail to
and and for 34 days i was i finally
decided okay i've used that my budget on
this you know if I don't get it now and
I tried all kinds of things about
instead of changing the you know one of
the thing things was well that the
problem is you see that we have we have
easy not easy nodes and not easy notes
in that algorithm the easy ones remember
we're the ones that the type was equal
to the value that meant that a serious a
series node of value one or parallel
know the value zero let's go easy and in
that and and when you when you make the
change to designate another child all
the easy all of your easy descendants we
changed their no longer you see and all
that and all the uneasy wants to become
easy so you're complimenting the easy
uneasy thing and that was and and I had
to be able to do that in my data
structure sort of in a lazy way instead
of instead of simultaneously and so I
kept going around and around and around
until finally I you know after four days
I i saw that problem and I got it out of
my system but that it but that was the
longest the longest part the rest of it
was was i would say about i mean
certainly the first program was it was
was was a day in the end it is gray SP
span i think was three days including
two days of debugging I mean you know
because the debugging was it was it was
the major thing and I didn't have the
phone ringing either you know I'm gonna
tired now so I don't have to answer
email so so so so I can work a lot
faster than most of you guys I'm retired
from email emails what I meant but the
but the code i find that eq i'm writing
this code and I'm and I'm putting the
English explanations in the code and
that actually saves me time I find if
I'm trying to write the program in
explaining it as I go to assuming that
somebody's going to read it even though
it's usually just you know from my own
benefit to rewrite when I wrote the
program I didn't know that I was going
to be footing
I I write it I try to explain it to
myself as I'm writing it and I find out
that it that does speed up the total
amount of time because I get my thoughts
in order much better that way I had a
somebody caught the little but little
joke I had in their pipe bomb well also
there was another one you know in there
if you compare the programs one of them
says this is the current edge of
interest and when you and when you go to
the corresponding comment in this one
it's the current interest bearing bond
so I have fun while doing this to ya any
other questions ok well now I have to
choose the people who has the best
questions i guess and i don't know how
to do the damn thing ok but i guess the
ones who asked the first to you two guys
are are in on it and I guess I think it
you two also I mean one already has the
book he doesn't need it right so so so
yeah ok so thanks very much